hi lupita how are you today i'm well
thank you
so i gotta ask
when it comes to jumping on set and you
gotta do all these action scenes you
gotta do the kind of things you guys do
in this movie how ready are you before
day one are you like doing months of
training beforehand are you ready to go
all the time
well yeah you we did do um training
beforehand i don't remember the period
but i feel like it was like
three four weeks um worth of training i
think and then you keep training as
you're doing the film
um so that you keep
you know uh buoyant with it so by the
time you're shooting
the scenes uh with the action in
question it's in your body and that's
the best way to do it and that's the way
we did it on this film so it's not as
daunting uh on the day because it's like
a dance that you've been practicing for
a very long time and you know you're you
know the your scene partners you know
your stunt partners and everything and
there's trust
um
with the with the team
and yeah you just get into it
is there a particular aspect of the
action training whether it's the
choreography or
maybe learning how to use the firearms
or whatever it is that you kind of fall
in love with and go
i i miss this when it's done
i love the hand-to-hand combat i do yeah
because that is the most dance-like you
know you do this and then i do this and
then i do that you know that sort of
thing though contact
um is the funnest bit uh
yeah because it just feels it's engaging
in a way
so i really did
enjoy that
what's most memorable to me in this film
is that i had to overcome my fear of
heights i had to jump from one floor to
another and it was really it was way
farther than i'd like it to be
but we trained up to it and i was
squealing all the way down the first few
times when i was learning how to do it
but but on the day i felt like a badass
because there were no screams left and i
was just like into it and did it and
everyone clapped because they knew they
knew how hard it had been for me to get
there
so now are you like signing yourself up
for bungee jumping and skydiving now
that you've conquered this
that would be a hard and fast no
no not today not ever
knock on wood
it's it's a it's a thrill to see all of
you together you know
on screen doing what you're doing in
this movie what was your favorite part
about having all these amazing women in
this you know female-led female-driven
action adventure
well i'd say that overall i i learned a
lot through observation you know all
these women have had incredible careers
i've watched them over the years they're
women that
i i i have admired in one way or another
and so to be with them on set and to see
how they conduct themselves and the
choices they make and just like beyond
their acting their etiquette and their
you know just their
people interact differently and you can
learn so much from from different
people's approach to the work so i
learned a lot from that and then also
these are all women with with various
versions of family and so to see them
navigate
um that aspect as well was really cool
you know
because
it's lovely to see a mother at work
and um
at her highest
um
uh
at her highest level and the juggling
and the negotiating of that and and
no balls dropping i mean
it's yeah it was incredible to see that
that's awesome now among the many things
that we're excited for for you we're
excited for the sequel to black panther
is there is there an update on leticia
how is she doing
i don't have any update
okay well if you could pick one person
to be joining your group in the sequel
to the 355 who would you love to have on
board with you
wow i haven't thought that far to be
very honest carlos because we've been
waiting with this film we did it two
years ago so because of pandemic and
everything the release of it was pushed
and everything so it's been such a long
time
since uh and i'm really looking forward
to like it being out in the world and
seeing what the reaction is and um
and going from there for a minute
i wasn't even sure it was gonna happen
you know so um i'm living in the present
moment i haven't really given much
thought to you two sequels
awesome well hey thank you so much for
the time congratulations on the film and
on uh getting over that fear of heights
that's a big deal
thank you